how come you guys don't talk about anime
anymore
uh
well there's only so much you can talk
about right yeah start going
live
yeah two of us are like i guess anime
youtubers well joey is the next sound of
a youtuber at this point and i still
watch it yeah you still i still watch i
just don't i just don't talk about it
you know what you know what's funny joey
has jerry now watches it as a hobby yeah
i've actually i've actually gone back to
watching it as a hobby as opposed to a
job as opposed to because it was a job
for me for the longest time and then
after a while i'm just like i kind of
got bored of talking about anime in
video form but i still enjoy the medium
so it's like but you see here's the
youtuber dilemma is that if you don't
make a video on it then you didn't do it
yeah right
so you know obviously my audience clowns
on me for that which is you know
understandable the people have a field
day with it but um yeah i don't know i
guess like i mean look because the thing
is we've always called ourselves trash
taste from the beginning right and we
always called ourselves uh as an anime
podcast we've sold it as an anime
podcast but i don't think we the
intention was to talk about
anime the entire time yeah
i never wanted to talk about it yeah
just in general you guys have it's like
every now and then we'll like we'll
throw it in as a topic right right but
it's not like the main focus yeah i
don't think yeah i mean it's funny
because even though it's like an ongoing
joke within our own fan base and our own
podcast that we don't talk about anime i
think it's actually just really helped
with our branding and i definitely
noticed this when i went to la and we
met you know a bunch of creators
including you and pretty much everyone
who met was just like oh that's the link
you're the anime guys and you're like oh
no
yeah and so like every guest we have in
la was just like yes i don't i don't
really like to watch a lot of animes and
we have to somehow talk about it for two
hours i'm like yeah no
no we don't i think because like the
only real like anime
episode we had was probably with like
pro cd yeah exactly then other than that
we maybe mentioned a flight
five minutes at a time but do you want
to talk about anime i
literally could not care less
wait about anime or about talking about
anime
okay
are you an anime fan william kind of
and what does that mean
most anime is like garbage yeah i mean
that's probably why it's like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
do people actually get mad if you say
anime's garbage no we say it all the
time it's literally what are we doing
like garbage i've ever heard my phone
make a sound like this
and it will never again
um define yeah define
it why is it garbage that's a garbage
fight
it a lot of times is very
cheap
what do you mean by that quite cheap as
in like like they crank it out as
quickly as possible and so everything is
like they're they're sort of
cherry-picking the most successful
tropes and strategies like instead of
making a really well fleshed out story
yeah just here's like dangling keys in
front of a building
i would argue american cartoons are also
like that i'm not saying this is not
about american guard
you've seen big mouth on netflix this
[ __ ] is ugly
i think i've seen because i don't watch
i don't watch any american cartoons
there's something about anime though
that like i think what i do like about
it is there's sort of the suspension of
the real world where yeah the the
language barrier makes it feel like
something that's very different from
what you're regularly consuming yeah
definitely definitely well i i think one
of the big issues with anime is you're
right a lot of it is the same copy paste
kind of story lines character tropes and
everything but when you find that really
really [ __ ] special and good anime
it's like to me the reason i'm a man i'm
an anime fan is because
it really is able to convey these kinds
of stories that you don't really find in
other mediums always like really really
hard right and i think right now we're
at a point where there's so many anime
being made that you're right 90 of it is
[ __ ] but
there are more and more like really
really [ __ ] great and amazing shows
that you can find on on a on a regular
basis man this is the most positive i've
ever talked about anime on this podcast
i just realized well we've never
introduced william yeah yeah
really you don't want to be because it
means they should
oh true true
um is there any anime you do like then
yeah yeah what do you what do you what
are your favorites yeah i i really like
that
[Music]
favorite anime
i i just i think that it's like if i was
to try to get anybody a brotherhood okay
yeah the first one yeah yeah if i had to
get anyone or i've had to convince
somebody to watch something that's
probably what i would try to convince
them to watch because it's very he
hasn't watched this yeah it's like it
feels like a very i don't know it's just
like uh closer to kind of western media
you know in a sense yeah and yeah i
think in a lot of ways there's some
other shows you like just list off some
of the eve
um
i i watched
part of attack on titan just sort of
kind of i don't know i don't like
political stuff
you don't like political just turns into
like a weird like governmental yeah
season two yeah
i mean it's like
i want to watch something explode
fantasy yeah you just want to like turn
your brain off yeah yeah
i like gundam
i've watched part of the og the old old
stuff can can be kind of slow compared
to like modern
yeah like
um i mean there's like some of the more
mainstream stuff like you know gundam
wing gundam seed zero zero gun on double
o gundam blooded orphans was really good
orphans i honestly can't remember the
names of anybody yeah
which one came when yeah
yeah i mean i think the i think the
reason why gundam is so confusing is
that there's just so many of them so
it's kind of like fate in this i i don't
mean to bring up fake but it's kind of
like that where there's just so much of
something that you don't even know kind
of like it's overwhelming yeah
yeah the names don't really help you
figure out which one comes because it's
not numerical yeah but maybe they could
have something like the uh resurrection
and then uh not the red the dead
okay there's some i gotta yeah get
direction
burial okay so that comes before
resurrection yeah yeah i was looking for
just a timeline i was like just give me
a timeline of like when each of them
came out because none of them even like
like time wise in their universe yeah or
like the branches you know like sort of
like the side right well the worst is
when the release date doesn't match up
to the oh my god
why did you guys choose to adapt this
completely out of order well the the
thing about gundam is that i guess it's
like the closest thing anime has kind of
like the mcu where there is like there
is like a timeline but every story is
basically self-contained but you know if
you have followed gundam from this
lineage back right at the beginning then
there is characters that appear in like
other things it's like little easter
whole political thing and they like they
seem to almost like take like an old
character and kind of bring them back as
like the new yeah like the grandchild
i am surprised that you like gundam
considering that you were just saying
you don't like politically i don't i
don't like that part again
so that's like saying like i really like
dune minus the political stuff you get
part way into gundam and then i get
bored and stop watching it
i don't know if i can say that you're a
fan of gondola formula one was all like
pit stops like what's with the racing
wait okay then what about so you
obviously just like the big robots
yeah though have you watched uh like
gorilla gone
that's that's that's that's that's
basically mine
my drill will pierce the heavens you
know
yeah you probably seen it
i'm telling you i don't watch it to
remember it
it's
it's funny because you say you don't
like political stuff but you're like
giant robots and i'm just like ninety
percent of all giant robot shows are
political people
you need like okay you need like a drop
of politics to justify the robot
fighting
but if there's an episode where there's
no robot fighting it's just politics
i'm out that's filler to me did you like
watch code kiosks do you remember kogi
us did you like that i don't remember
but i think i watched all of it which
means politics there's a lot of politics
in that but there was
[Music]
uh it's actually a good way to find
stuff
just go through like find something you
like yeah and then go to their wikipedia
and just dig through the entire catalog
um i found a bunch of you you do
something that 99 of anime fans don't do
it you exactly you should 100 do that
like go to like the director or any any
literally anybody that works on these
shows because it seems like they all
have like the same aspiration so if they
direct it or if they did this or that
like they all have different things
they've worked on yeah they kind of
contributed to i mean i don't understand
why more anime fans do this because this
is a normal practice in like say the
movie industry or
i would argue that they do do it for
film directors like you know if you
watch a hosoda mamoru movie or a shinkai
makoto movie then you're just like oh i
want to see what other movies they made
but i feel they don't really do that
when it comes to tv animations i guess
like my tv series because tv series a
lot of times is adapting something new
but yeah a lot of directors in anime i
know have such a unique style
um and i guess some of the biggest names
have like the most unique style like
masaki yuasa yeah you might not know his
names but if you've seen his work you
know when you see one of his words if
you watch something like ping pong the
animation or dev man cry baby or
something like that but same with
hideaki anna as well he's like such a
big name in the anime industry so from
evangelion i got to something called
like the secret of blue water oh my god
you're going way back
[Music]
that's a deep card chelsea's looking at
me right now so we found a website
because you can't you like some of this
stuff you literally can't watch anywhere
yeah yeah yeah like you can't pay for it
you can't stream well even galen you
couldn't watch it for like 20 years
later yeah it's like free money
it only took like netflix to acquire the
rights to evangelium before you could
stream god knows how much money they
paid for that exactly right exactly yeah
they basically like you can like
watching their other
you know work
it's funny that you can kind of
see them as an artist because they kind
of get stuck on the same idea oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah so there was a lot of
like very sort of linear like very like
very parallel story lines
um in secret of blue water and
evangelion of like this you know it's
just it's it's funny to see that they're
almost like like they've been working
towards this one story yeah across
multiple completely separate
yeah works exactly what's the guy made
belle called he he made his sources in
the same movie yeah yeah yeah yeah it
feels like
he did the digimon movie and was just
like i'm going to make summer wars which
is just the digimon movie minus the
digimon again and they're like
plagiarizing themselves
you can't it's not copying you
before it's just i don't know it's uh
well there's also mako shinkai now who i
think after doing your name yeah was
just like weather porn the movie let's
do it again yo he's going like rad wimps
on speed dogs like yo bro you you know
i'm gonna need you for this next
soundtrack bro yeah but yeah when i
found that i was the happiest to find i
think like the best one was we talked
about a little bit on our podcast it's
called memories
oh my god ultimate cards here are yeah
my that is brilliant it is so good so
good like the the just the animation
alone is like i have never seen anything
like that magnetic rose is oh my god i'm
sorry you're the only one i know who's
seen it yeah i know
oh my god
i wish they made [ __ ] like this yeah
like i it makes me sad that that is not
something anybody wants to put money in
it is basically akira in space yes
it's [ __ ] insane it's so good
you're an anime fan you are an animal
you are not you're like kind of a yeah
you are an enemy
you're talking about even i haven't seen
that maybe i'm just talking [ __ ] about
like more modern stuff are you gonna are
you going down like the martin scorsese
[Music]
what i used to watch was anime
[Laughter]
well i i think
probably one of the biggest reasons why
you don't enjoy modern anime is it seems
like you enjoy sci-fi
giant robots uh two genres that really
are not thriving in the modern i don't
know why is is sci-fi just like has that
has it just gone downhill in general
because i think it's just been
completely overwritten right now by the
fantasy genre and then within the
fantasy genre mostly the second genre i
feel like every you know decade or two
it always flip-flops between whether
fantasy or like space and futuristic oh
yes of course right and right now we're
in like a giant d and d boom and fantasy
just seems to be like the thing right
now and i'm sure in future it'll swap
back to space in like 10 or 20 years
sure this is like a scope creep
everyone's trying to one-up each other
yeah yeah like our robot's bigger our
robot's bigger or they call it the power
creep uh yeah but it's like creep yeah
but it's like in the whole genre itself
yeah each show has to outdo the other
side yeah well i mean when you uh when
we had like gurren lagann which was
literally you know spoiler small spoiler
alert although it doesn't really you
know change the enjoyment of the show uh
when they literally are [ __ ] using
universe no uh galaxies hurricanes i'm
like where there's there's nowhere to go
they're standing on galaxies to fight
there's nowhere to [ __ ] go from here
yeah and
especially like you look you look at
something like dragon ball super and
they're like okay goku is the most
powerful being in the universe where can
we go from here he's the most powerful
being in the multiverse okay but where
can we go from here well i don't i don't
know now i don't know there's uh there's
literally no no way you can take that
but
i guess one of the big things that i've
missed is a lot of just old school
sci-fi shows because i feel like a lot
of
i i feel like those are some of my
favorite types of stories but it's so so
rare nowadays not even an anime just to
find like a good sci-fi story
um which is why i've really really
[ __ ] enjoyed dune
yeah i was about to say they've kind of
had to resort to going back to older
media exactly and older franchises and
kind of just like re-imagining it for
the modern audience and again i think
that's why like dune was so good is
because like that's like a story that
was probably quite you know abundant
when it was first around like in the 80s
and 90s and stuff like that but like
yeah like now it's like other than maybe
like star wars like the news the new
song i don't care the three new star
wars trilogies other than that like i
can't really think of like a good sci-fi
show that has come out recently i think
it's a lot of work to come up with like
a whole yeah yeah everything and then
even more work to try to tell a cohesive
narrative because you can just be like
it's a fantasy world right yeah you know
there's a guy selling bread and there's
a guy selling apples and everything's
better you don't have to think about the
logic of the wall yeah you're like oh
that's how it used to be